هذه قصة عن مزرعة ليس فقط
أي مزرعة ولكن مكان ينبت فيه الخيال
من التربة التي نزرعها حقًا
غريب الأطوار البرية الرائعة الأشياء اللذيذة
بصراحة ، الأغرب كان أفضل مثل
ما schewe oka badger flame beet
squash eeny butterfly sorrel
sorrel Picchu berries  توت الصنوبر الأبيض
الفراولة في جبال الألب ، انتظر ما
كان آخر شيء جيد لم تسمع به من قبل عن
نبات الثلج ، لم يكن لدى آرون تروي آرون
أي نية للدخول في
الزراعة ، لقد خططت بالفعل للحصول على
درجة الماجستير ثم الدكتوراه من أجل
تدريس  دراسة الدين في الكلية ،
حصلت على 180 كاملة من 180
بفضل والديه بعد إدارة
متجر أزهار ناجح ،
حاول آرون وأخواته إقناعهم بالتقاعد ولكن
كان لدى والديه خطط أخرى
كان تقاعدهما هو الذهاب لشراء مزرعة بدلاً من ذلك
[موسيقى  ]
بدأوا في زراعة
الخضار الكورية لأسواق التجزئة ولكن بعد ذلك
انخرط آرون وأخذت الأمور
منعطفًا غريبًا بعد أن بدأت في
الحصول على يدي  سحب الأعشاب المتسخة
المهووسة بظروف النمو ،
درجة حرارة الماء الخفيف ، الرطوبة ، كل شيء
حولها أصبح مجرد تجربة مرتفعة واحدة
تلو الأخرى ، وأعتقد
أن هذا هو المكان الذي كنت فيه مدمن مخدرات وكل
ذلك كان يتردد صداه بشكل أفضل
معي من وضع أنفي في الكتب
طوال الوقت  بصراحة تامة بمجرد أن
يتعرف على حياة المزرعة ،
أخذ الطريق إلى مستوى آخر ، بدأنا
في تجربة الكثير من الخضر المختلفة ،
ثم انفجر ذلك بسرعة كبيرة
في مجموعة كاملة من
المنتجات الأخرى غير المألوفة نسبيًا مثل الخوخ والتوت
والطماطم الخضراء الحلوة التي لم
يسمعها أحد  من
مفضلتي oka و ma schewe
التي سمع عنها عدد أقل من الناس ناهيك عن تذوقها بالفعل ،
كان الهدف دائمًا هو استهداف
المطاعم الراقية أولاً وقبل كل شيء
لأنني أعتقد أن هناك الكثير من
التأثير المتدفق على المكونات الجديدة والغريبة.
كيف يمكن للمرء أن يتحول من
بيع سلع التجزئة بالجملة إلى توريد
مطاعم راقية فاخرة ، لقد
بدأت حرفياً ما  يزور King Cold بمجرد أن
بدأ الطهاة في رؤية
ما كنا ننموه لدهشتي ، فقد
أذهلهم الشيء الجيد الذي أحصل عليه بانتظام
مثل لا أصدق أنك
تزرع هذا جيدًا ، إنه الجانب التخصصي
حيث يتماشى هوسي
مع  في محاولة للتعرف على
الأشياء غير المألوفة ، هناك الكثير مما يمكن قوله
حول هذه الأطعمة غير المألوفة في
العالم والتي نحتاج حقًا إلى تعريف
المزيد من الأشخاص بها لأنه كلما
زاد انتشارنا ، تحدث المزيد من المحادثات
حول تلك الأطعمة التي لا
تحتوي على طعام
.
أنت